i talked to another shop owner who had  an idea  engraved the vin number on cats that's  what i've been saying since the  beginning of this if the vin number was  on the converter and the recyclers were  made to be required to keep a record of  the vin number and who sold it to him  this will stop because it's that simple  somebody makes a police report hey my  vin number this part was stolen they put  that out to all the recyclers and say  hey do you have a hit on any of these  vin numbers and if they're doing their  due diligence they'll have the vin  number who sold it to them and when and  why that person had it it'd be that  simple okay you got the vin number cool  who sold it to you this guy they go  knock on his door  problem solved